our welcome
so look just six months ago it seems a
lifetime ago but it really was just six
months ago climate seemed to be on the
lips of every thinking person on the
planet
recent events seem to have swept it all
away from our attention how worried are
you about that well first of all Chris
thank you so much for inviting me to
have this conversation people are
reacting differently to the climate
crisis in the midst of these other great
challenges that have taken over our
awareness appropriately one reason is
something that you mentioned people get
the fact that when scientists are
warning us and ever more dire terms and
setting their hair on fire so to speak
it's why best to listen to what they're
saying and I think that lesson has begun
to sink in in a new way another
similarity by the way is that the
climate crisis like the kovat nineteen
pandemic has revealed in a new way the
shocking in justices and inequalities
and disparities that affect communities
of color and low-income communities
there are differences the climate crisis
has effects that are not measured in
years as the pandemic is but
consequences that are measured in
centuries and even longer and the other
difference is that instead of depressing
economic activity to deal with the
climate crisis as nations around the
world have had to do with kovat nineteen
we have the opportunity to create tens
of millions of new jobs that sounds like
a political phrasing but it's literally
true for the last five years the fastest
growing job in the US has been solar
installer the second-fastest has been
wind turbine technician and the oxford
review of economics just
a few weeks ago pointed the way to a
very jobs rich recovery if we emphasize
renewable energy and sustainability
technology so I think we are crossing a
tipping point and you need only look at
the recovery plans that are being
presented in nations around the world to
see that they're very much focused on a
green recovery I mean one obvious impact
of that pandemic is it has brought the
world's economy to a shuddering halt
and thereby you know reducing greenhouse
gas emissions
I mean how big an effect has that been
and is it unambiguously good news well
it's a little bit of an illusion Chris
and you need only look back to the Great
Recession in 2008 and nine when there
was a 1% decline in emissions but then
in 2010 they came roaring back turning
their recovery with a four percent
increase the latest estimates are that
emissions will go down by at least five
percent during this induced coma as
economist Paul Krugman perceptively
described it but whether it goes back
the way it did after the Great Recession
is in part up to us at if these green
recovery plans are actually implemented
and I know many countries that are
determined to implement them then we
need not repeat that pattern after all
this whole process is occurring during a
period when the cost of renewable energy
and electric vehicles batteries and a
range of other sustainability approaches
are continuing to fall in price and
they're becoming much more competitive
just a quick reference to how fast this
is five years ago electricity from solar
and wind was cheaper than electricity
from fossil fuels and only 1% of the
world
this year it's cheaper in two-thirds of
the world and five years from now it
will be cheaper in virtually 100% of the
world
Eevee's will be cost-competitive within
two years and then will continue falling
in price and so there are changes
underway that could interrupt the
pattern we saw after the Great Recession
the reason those pricing differentials
happen in different parts of the world
is obviously just because there's
different amounts of sunshine and wind
there and sort of different building
costs and so forth yeah well yes and
government policies also account for a
lot of the world is continuing to
subsidize fossil fuels at a ridiculous
amount more so in the develop in many
developing countries than in the US and
developed countries but it's subsidized
here as well but everywhere in the world
when then solar will be cheaper as a
source of electricity than fossil fuels
so within a few years I think I've had
it said that the fall in emissions
caused by the pandemic isn't that much
more than actually the four that we will
need every single year if we're to meet
emissions targets I mean is that true
and if so doesn't that seem impossibly
daunting it does seem daunting but first
look at the number that number came from
a study a little over a year ago
released by the IPCC as to what it would
take to keep the Earth's temperatures
from increasing more than 1.5 degrees
Celsius and yes the annual reductions
would be significant on the order of
what we've seen with the pandemic and
yes that does seem daunting however we
do have the opportunity to make some
fairly dramatic changes and the plan is
not a mystery you start with the two
sectors that are closest to an effective
transition electricity generation as I
mentioned and last year 2019
if you look at all of the new
electricity generation built all around
the world seventy-two percent of it was
from solar and wind and already without
the continuing subsidies for fossil
fuels we would see the many more of
these plants being shut down there are
some new fossil plans being built but
many more are being shut down and where
transportation is concerned the second
sector ready to go in addition to the
cheaper prices for EVs that I made
reference to before there are some of 45
jurisdictions around the world national
regional and municipal where laws have
been vast beginning a phase-out of
internal combustion engines even India
said that by 2030 less than 10 years
from now it will be illegal to sell any
new internal combustion engines in India
there are many other examples so the
past small reductions may not be an
accurate guide to the kind we can
achieve with serious national and plans
and a focused global effort to help us
understand just the big picture here Wow
I think before the pandemic the world
was emitting about 55 Giga tons of what
they call co2 equivalent so that
includes other greenhouse gases like
methane dialed up to be the equivalent
of of co2 and am i right in saying that
the IPCC which is the global
organization of scientists is
recommending that too the only way to
fix this crisis is to get that number
from 55 to zero by 2050 at the very
latest and that even then that there's a
chance that we will end up with
temperature rises more like two degrees
Celsius rather than 1.5 I mean that is
that that's approximately the the big
picture of what the IPCC is recommending
that's correct the the global goal
established in the
conference is to get to net zero on a
global basis by 2050 and many people
quickly add that that really means a 45
to 50 percent reduction by 2030 to make
that pathway to net zero feasible and
that that kind of timeline is is the
kind of timeline where people can even
imagine it's just it's hard to think of
policy over 30 years so so that's
actually a very good shorthand that
humanity's task is to cut emissions in
half by 2030 approximately speaking
which which I think boils down to about
a 7 or 8 percent reduction a year
something like that if I'm if I'm not
wrong not quite not quite that large but
but close yes so so it is something like
the effect that we've experienced this
year may may be necessary this year
we've done it by basically shutting down
the economy you're talking about a way
of doing it over the coming years that
actually gives economic some economic
growth and a new job so to talk more
about that like you've referred to
energy changing our energy sources
changing how we transport if we did
those things how much of the problem
does that solve well we can get to well
well in addition to doing the two
sectors that I mentioned we also have to
deal with manufacturing and all the use
cases that require temperatures of a
thousand degrees Celsius and there are
solutions there as well I'll come back
and mention an exciting one that Germany
has just embarked upon we also have to
tackle regenerative agriculture there is
the opportunity to sequester a great
deal of carbon in top soils around the
world by changing the agricultural
techniques there is a farmer led
movement to do that we need to also
retrofit buildings we need to change our
management of forests and the ocean but
let me just mention two things briefly
first of all the high temperature use
cases Angela Merkel
just ten days ago with the leadership of
her Minister Peter altmeyer who's a good
friend and a great public servant have
just embarked on a green hydrogen
strategy to make hydrogen with a zero
marginal cost renewable energy and just
a word on that Chris you've heard about
the intermittency of wind and solar
doesn't Solar doesn't produce
electricity when the sun's not shining
and when doesn't when the winds not
blowing but batteries are getting better
and these technologies are becoming much
more efficient and powerful so that for
an increasing number of hours each day
they're producing often way more
electricity than can be used so what to
do with it the marginal cost for the
next kilowatt hour is zero so all of a
sudden the very energy intensive process
of cracking hydrogen from water becomes
economically feasible and it can be
substituted for coal and gas and that's
already being done there's a Swedish
company already making steel with green
hydrogen and as I say Germany has just
embarked on a major new initiative to do
that I think they're pointing the way
for the rest of the world and we're
building retrofits are concerned just a
moment on this because about 20 to 25
percent of the global warming pollution
in the world and in the u.s. comes from
inefficient buildings that were
constructed by companies and individuals
who were trying to be competitive in the
marketplace and keep their margins
except ibly high and thereby skimping on
insulation and the right windows and
LEDs and the rest and yet the person who
or a company that buys that building or
leases that building they want their
monthly utility bills much lower so
there are now ways to close that
so-called agent principle divide the
differing incentives for the Builder and
occupier and we can retrofit buildings
it with a program that lit
really pays for itself over three to
five years and we can put tens of
millions of people to work in jobs that
by definition cannot be outsourced
because they exist in every single
community and and we really ought to get
serious about doing this because we're
gonna need all those jobs to get does
sustainable prosperity in the aftermath
of this pandemic just coming back to the
hydrogen economy that you referred to
there when some people hear that they
think oh are you talking about hydrogen
fueled cars and they've heard that that
probably won't be a winning strategy but
you're but you're thinking much more
broadly than that I think that it's not
just hydrogen as a kind of storage
mechanism to act as a buffer for
renewable energy but also hydrogen could
be essential for some of the other
processes in the economy like making
steel making cement that are sort of
fundamentally carbon intensive processes
right now but could be transformed if we
had if we had much cheaper sources of
hydrogen is that right yes I was always
skeptical about hydrogen Chris
principally because it's been so
expensive to to make it to crack it out
of water as they say but the
game-changer has been the incredible
abundance of solar and wind electricity
and volumes and amounts that that people
didn't expect and all of a sudden it's
cheap enough to use for these very
energy intensive processes like creating
green hydrogen I'm still a bit skeptical
about using it in vehicles Toyota's been
betting on that for 25 years and it
hasn't really worked for them
never say never maybe it will but I
think it's most useful for these
high-temperature industrial processes
and we already have a pathway for
decarbonizing transportation with
electricity that's working extremely
well Tesla's going to be soon the most
valuable automobile company in the world
already in the US and they're about to
over
Toyota there is now a semi truck company
that's been stood up by Tesla and
another that is going to be a hybrid
with electricity and green hydrogen so
we'll see whether or not they can make
it work in that application but I think
electricity is preferable for cars and
drugs we're coming to some community
questions in a minute let me ask you
though about nuclear some
environmentalists believe that nuclear
or maybe new generation nuclear power is
as an essential part of the equation if
we're to get to a truly clean future
clean energy future
are you still pretty skeptical on
nuclear ow
well the markets skeptical about it
Chris
it's been a crushing disappointment for
for me and for so many I used to
represent Oak Ridge where nuclear energy
began and when I was a young congressman
I was a booster I was very enthusiastic
about it but the cost overruns and the
problems in in building these plants
have become so severe that utilities
just don't have an appetite for them and
it's become the most expensive source of
electricity now let me hasten to add
that there are some older nuclear
reactors that have more useful time that
could be added on to their lifetimes and
like a lot of environmentalists I've
come to the view that if they can be
determined to be safe they they should
be allowed to continue operating for a
time but where new nuclear power plants
are concerned here's a way to look at it
if you are you've been a CEO Chris if
you were the CEO of a I guess you still
are if you were the CEO of an electric
utility and you told your executive team
I want to build a nuclear power plant
two of the first questions you would ask
are number one how much will it cost and
there's not a single
engineering consulting firm that I've
been able to find anywhere in the world
that will give put their name on an
opinion giving you a cost estimate they
just don't know a second question you
would ask is how long will it take to
build it so we can start selling the
electricity and again the answer you
will get is we have no idea so if you
don't know how much it's going to cost
and you don't know when it's going to be
finished and you already know that the
electricity is more expensive than the
alternate ways to produce it that's
gonna be a little discouraging and in
fact that's been the case for utilities
around the world okay so there's
definitely an interesting debate there
but we're gonna come on to some
community questions let's have the first
of those questions that please from
Prasanna Chakrabarti people who are
skeptical of covert and of climate
change seem to be skeptical of science
in general it may be that the singular
message from scientists gets diluted and
convoluted how do we fix that yeah
that's a that's a great question
prasanta boy I'm trying to put this
succinctly and shortly I think that
there has been a feeling that experts in
general have kind of let the us down and
that feeling is much more pronounced in
the US than in most other countries and
I think that the considered opinion of
what we call experts has been diluted
over the last few decades by the
unhealthy dominance of big money in our
political system which has found ways to
to really twist economic policy to
benefit elites and this sounds a little
radical but it's actually what has
happened and we have gone for more than
four years without any meaningful
increase in middle income pay and where
the injustice experienced
african-americans and other communities
of color concern the differential in pay
between african-americans and majority
Americans is the same as it was in 1968
and the the family wealth the net worth
it takes 11 and a half so-called typical
african-american families to make up the
net worth of one so-called typical of
white American family and you look at
the the soaring incomes in the top one
or top one-tenth of one percent and
people say wait a minute
whoever the experts were that designed
these policies they haven't been doing a
good job for me
final point Chris there has been an
assault on reason there's been a war
against truth there has been a strategy
maybe it was best known as a strategy
decades ago by the tobacco companies who
hired actors and dressed them up as
doctors to falsely reassure people that
there were no health consequences from
smoking cigarettes and 100 million
people died as a result that same
strategy of diminishing the significance
of truth diminishing as someone said the
authority of knowledge I think that has
made it kind of open season on any
inconvenient truth forgive another buzz
phrase but it is apt but we cannot
abandon our devotion to the best
available evidence tested in recent
discourse and used as the basis for the
the best policies we can form and is it
possible out that one consequence of the
pandemic is actually a growing number of
people have revisited their opinions on
scientists I mean you've had a chance in
the last few months to say do I trust my
political leader or do I trust this the
scientist in terms of what they're
saying about this virus maybe lessons
from that could be carried forward
well you know I think the if the polling
is accurate people do a trust their
doctors a lot more than some of the
politicians who have who seemed to have
a vested interest in pretending the
pandemic isn't real and if you look at
the incredible bust at president Trump's
rally in Tulsa a stadium of nineteen
thousand people with less than one third
filled according to the fire marshal you
saw the empty seats if you saw the news
clips so even the most loyal Trump
supporters must have decided to trust
their doctors and the medical advice
rather than doctor Donald Trump with a
little help from the tick-tock
generation per chance yeah well but that
didn't affect the turnout what they did
very cleverly it's not cheering him on
what they did was affect the the Trump
White House's expectations they're the
reason why he went out a couple of days
beforehand and said we've had a million
people sign up but they didn't prevent
they didn't take seats that others could
have otherwise taken they didn't affect
but turn out just the expectations okay
let's have our next question here are
you concerned the world will rush back
to the use of the private car out of
fear of using shared public
transportation well that could that
could actually be one of the
consequences that absolutely now the
trends on mass transit we're already
inching in the wrong direction because
of uber and lyft and the the
ride-sharing services and if autonomy
ever reaches the goals that its
advocates have hoped for then that may
also have a similar effect but there's
no doubt that some people are going to
be probably a little
more reluctant to take mass
transportation until the until the fear
of this pandemic is well and truly gone
yeah might need a vaccine on that one
yes question sinara Lutra thank you for
this question from LA given the
temperature rise in the Arctic this past
week seems like the rate we're losing
our carbon sinks like permafrost or
forests is accelerating faster than we
predicted are our models too focused on
human emissions I'm just in question
well the the models are focused on the
factors that have led to these
incredible temperature spikes in the
north of the Arctic Circle
they were predicted they have been
predicted and one of the reasons for it
is that as the snow and ice cover melts
the sun's incoming rays are no longer
reflected back into space at a 90
percent rate and instead when they fall
on the dark Tundra or the dark ocean
they're absorbed at ninety percent rate
so that's a magnifier of the of the
warming in the Arctic and this has been
predicted there are a number of other
consequences that are also in the models
but some of them may have to be
recalibrated thee the scientists are
freshly concerned that the emissions of
both the co2 and methane from the
thawing Tundra could be larger than they
had hoped they would be there's also
just been a brand new study I won't
spend time on this because it deals with
a kind of a geeky term called climate
sensitivity which has been a factor in
the models with large error bars because
it's so hard to pin down but the latest
evidence indicates worryingly that the
sensitivity may be greater than they had
thought and and we will have an even
more daunting task that shouldn't
discourage us
I truly believe that once we cross this
tipping point and I do believe we're
doing it now as I've said then I think
we're gonna find a lot of ways to speed
up the emissions reductions we'll take
one more question from the community hah
geoengineering is making extraordinary
progress Exxon is investing in
technology Exxon is investing in
technology from global thermostat that
seems promising what do you think these
air and water carbon capture
technologies stephen petronio yeah well
you and I talked about this before Chris
I'm been strongly opposed to conducting
an unplanned global experiment that
could go wildly wrong and most are
really scared of that approach however
the term geoengineering is a nuanced
term that covers a lot if you want to
paint roofs white to reflect more energy
from the the the cityscapes that's not
gonna bring a danger of a runaway effect
and there's some other things that are
loosely called geoengineering like that
which are fine but the idea of blocking
out the sun's rays
that's insane in my opinion turns out
plants need sunlight for photosynthesis
and solar panels need sunlight for
produce producing electricity from the
sun's rays and the consequences of
changing everything we know and and and
pretending that the consequences are
going to precisely cancel out the
unplanned experiment of global warming
that we already have underway you know
their glitches in our thinking one of
them is called the single solution bias
and there are people who just have a
hunger to say well that one solution we
just need to latch onto that and do the
damn my words as well it's nuts but let
me push back on this just just a little
bit because because so let's say that we
agreed that a single solution or or
nothing
attempt at geoengineering is is crazy
but there are scenarios where the world
looks at emissions and just season 10 10
years time let's say that they are just
not coming down fast enough and that we
are in risk of several other liftoff
events where that this train will just
get away from us and we will be we will
see temperature rises of three four five
six seven degrees and and you know all
of civilization is at risk surely there
is an approach to geoengineering that
could be modeled in a way on the way
that we approach medicine like for
hundreds of years people we don't really
understand the human body people will
try interventions and some of them would
work and some of them wouldn't isn't no
one says in medicine you know go in and
take an all-or-nothing decision on on
someone's life but they do say let's try
some stuff if if an experiment can be
reversible if it's plausible in the
first place if there's reason to think
that it might work we actually owe it to
the future health of humanity to try at
least some types of tests to see what
could work so so small tests to see
whether for example seeding of something
in the ocean might create innocence in a
non-threatening way carbon sinks or
maybe a rather than filling the
atmosphere with sulfur dioxide a smaller
experiment that was you know was not
that big a deal but to see whether
cost-effectively you could reduce the
temperature a little bit surely that
that isn't completely crazy in is at
least something we should be thinking
about in case these other measures don't
work well there have already been such
experiments to seed the ocean to see if
that can increase the uptake of co2 and
the experiments were an unmitigated
failure
as many predicted they would be but that
again is the kind of approach that's
very different from putting tinfoil
strips in the atmosphere orbiting the
Earth that was the way that solar
geoengineering proposal started now
they're focusing on chalk so we have
chalk dust all over everything but more
serious than that is the fact that it
might not be reversible but now that
that's the rhetoric response is that
really the like the amount of dust that
you need to make to drop by a degree or
two wouldn't result in chalk dust over
everything it would be it would be
unbelievably like it would be less than
the dust that people experience every
day anyway yeah I mean I I don't know
first of all I don't know how you do a
small experiment in the atmosphere and
and secondly if we were to take that
approach we would have to steadily
increase the amount of whatever
substance they decided we'd have to
increase it every single year and if we
ever stopped then there would be a
sudden snapback it like the Picture of
Dorian Gray that old cookin and movie
where suddenly all of the things caught
up with you at once the the fact that
anyone is even considering these
approaches Chris is a measure of a
feeling of desperation that some have
begun to feel which I understand but I
don't think it should drive us toward
these reckless experiments and by the
way using your analogy to experimental
cancer treatments for example you
usually get informed consent from the
patient getting informed consent from
seven point eight billion people who
have no voice and no say who are subject
to the
potentially catastrophic consequences of
this wackadoodle a proposal that
somebody comes up with to try to
rearrange the entire Earth's atmosphere
and hope and pretend that it's going to
cancel out the fact that we're putting a
hundred and fifty two million tons of
heat-trapping man-made global warming
pollution into the sky every day that's
what's really insane a scientist decades
ago compared it this way he said if you
had two people on a sinking boat and one
of them one of them says you know we
could probably use some mirrors to to
signal to shore to get them to build a
sophisticated wave generating machine
that will cancel out the rocking of the
boat by these guys in the back of the
boat or you could get them to stop
rocking the boat and that's what we need
to do we need to stop what's causing the
crisis yeah but that's a great story but
if but if the effort to stop the people
rocking in the back of the boat is as
complex as the scientific proposal you
just outlined where it where as the
experiment to stop the waves is actually
as simple as telling the people to stop
rocking the boat that story changes and
I just I just think that I think you're
right that the issue of informed consent
is a really challenging one but I mean
no one gave can informed consent to do
all the other things we're doing to the
app to the atmosphere and I agree that
the moral panic issue is the moral
hazard issue is is is worrying that if
you if we became dependent on
geoengineering and and took our way our
efforts to do the rest that would be
tragic it just seems like I wish I wish
it was possible to have a nuanced debate
of people saying you know what there's
multiple dials to a very complex problem
we're gonna have to adjust several of
them very very carefully and keep
talking to each other like wouldn't
wouldn't that be a goal to just try and
have a more nuanced debate about this
rather than all of that geoengineering
can't work well I've said some of it you
know the the benign forms that I'd
mentioned
I'm not ruling those out but blocking
the sun's rays from the earth not only
do you affect seven point eight billion
people you affect the plants and the
animals and the ocean currents and the
wind currents and natural processes that
we're in danger of disrupting even more
so you know they're techno optimism is
something I've engaged in in the past
but to to latch on to some brand-new
technological solution to rework the
entire Earth's natural system because
somebody thinks he's clever enough to do
it in a way that precisely cancels out
the consequences of using the atmosphere
as an open sewer for heat trapping
man-made gases it's much more important
to stop using the atmosphere as an open
sewer that's what the problem is all
right well we don't real great that that
is the most important thing for sure and
speaking of which do you believe the
world needs carbon pricing and is there
any prospect for getting there yes yes
to both questions for decades almost
every economist who's asked about the
climate crisis says well we just need to
put a price on carbon and and I have
certainly been in favor of that approach
but it is daunting nevertheless there
are 43 jurisdictions around the world
that already have a price on carbon
we're seeing it in Europe they finally
straightened out their carbon pricing
mechanism it's an emissions trading
version of it we have places that have
put a tax on carbon that's the approach
the economists prefer China is beginning
to implement its national emissions
trading program California and quite a
few other states in the US are already
doing it it can be given back to
people in a revenue-neutral way but the
opposition to it chris at which you've
noted is impressive enough that we do
have to take other approaches and I
would say most climate activists are now
saying look let's don't make the best
the enemy of the better there are other
ways to do this as well we need every
solution we can we can rationally employ
including by regulation and often when
the political difficulty of a proposal
becomes too difficult in a
market-oriented approach the the
fallback is with regulation and it's
been given a bad name regulation but
many places are doing it I mentioned
phasing out internal combustion engines
that's an example there are 160 cities
in the u.s. that have already by
regulation ordered that within a date
certain a hundred percent of all their
electricity will have to come from
renewable sources and again the market
forces that are driving the cost of
renewable energy and sustainability
solutions ever downward that gives us
the the wind at our back this is working
in our favor I mean the pushback on
carbon pricing often goes further from
parts of the environmental movement
which is to a push back on the role of
business in general businesses actually
well capitalism is blamed for the
climate crisis because of unrelenting
growth to the point where people don't
trust many people don't trust business
to be part of the solution the only way
to go forward is to regulate to force
businesses to do the right thing do you
think the business has to be part of the
solution well definitely because the
allocation of capital needed to solve
this crisis is greater than what
governments can handle
but but let me and businesses are
beginning many businesses are beginning
to play a very constructive role there
they're getting a demand that they do so
from their customers from their
investors from from their boards from
their executive teams from their
families and by the way the the rising
generation is demanding a brighter
future and when CEOs interview potential
new hires they find that the new hires
are interviewing them and they want to
make a nice income but they want to be
able to tell their family and friends
and peers that they're doing something
more than just making money one
illustration of how this new generation
is changing Chris there are 65 colleges
in the u.s. right now where the college
young Republican clubs have joined
together to jointly demand that the
Republican National Committee change its
policy on climate lest they lose that
entire generation this is a global
phenomenon
the gretta generation is now leading
this in so many ways and it if you look
at the polling again the vast majority
of young Republicans are demanding a
change on climate policy this is really
a movement that it is building still I
was gonna ask you about that because one
of the most painful things and I over
the last 20 years has just been how
climate has been politicized and
certainly in the in the US you've
probably thought yourself at the heart
of that a lot at the time with people
attacking you personally in the most
merciless and unfair ways often I mean
do you really see signs that that might
be changing led by the next generation
yeah there's no question about it I
don't want to rely on polls too much
I've mentioned them already but there
was a new one that came out that looked
at the wavering Trump supporters those
who supported him strongly in the past
want to do so again the number one issue
surprisingly to some that is giving them
pause is the craziness of President
Trump and his administration on climate
we're seeing big majorities of the
Republican Party overall saying that
they're ready to start exploring some
real solutions to the climate crisis I
think that we're really getting there no
question about it
I mean you've been the figurehead for
raising this issue and you happen to be
a Democrat is there anything that you
can personally do to cut I don't know to
open the tent to welcome people to try
and say this is beyond politics dear
friends
yeah well I've tried all of those things
and maybe it's made a little positive
difference I've worked with the
Republicans extensively and and you know
well after I left the White House I had
Newt Gingrich and Pat Robertson and
other prominent Republicans appear on
national TV ads with me saying we've got
to solve the climate crisis but the
petroleum industry has really doubled
down enforcing discipline within the
Republican Party I mean look at the
attacks they've launched against the
Pope when he came out with his
encyclical and and was demonized not by
all for sure but there were hawks in the
anti climate movement who immediately
started training their guns on on Pope
Francis and there there are many other
examples they enforce discipline and try
to make it a partisan issue even as
Democrats reach out to try to to make it
bipartisan I totally agree with you that
it should not be a partisan issue it
didn't used to be but it's been
artificially weaponized as an issue I
mean the CEOs of oil companies also have
kids who are talking to
them do it feels like some of them are
moving and are trying to invest in
trying to find ways of being part of the
future do you see signs of that yeah I
mean I think that business leaders
including in the oil and gas companies
are hearing from their families they're
hearing from their friends they're
hearing from their employees and by the
way we've seen in the in the tech
industry some mass walkouts by employees
who are demanding that some of the tech
companies do more and get serious I'm so
proud of Apple forgive me for
parenthetically praising Apple you know
I'm on the board but I'm such a big fan
of Tim Cook and my colleagues at Apple
it's an example of a tech company that's
really doing fantastic things and
there's some others as well there are
others in in in many industries but the
the pressures on the oil and gas
companies are quite extraordinary
you know BP just wrote down twelve and a
half billion dollars worth of oil and
gas assets but and said they're never
gonna see the light of day two-thirds of
the fossil fuels that have already been
discovered cannot be burned and will not
be burned and so that's a big economic
risk to the global economy like the
subprime mortgage crisis we've got
twenty two trillion dollars of subprime
carbon assets and just yesterday there
was a major report that the fracking
industry in the US it is seeing now a
wave of bankruptcies because the price
of the fracked gas and oil has fallen
below levels that make them competitive
make them economic is the shorthand of
what's happened there that electric cars
and electric technologies and solar and
so forth have driven have helped drive
down the price of oil to the point where
huge months the reserves just can't be
can't be developed
profitably yes that's it that that
that's mainly it the the projections for
energy sources in the next several years
uniformly predict that electricity from
wind and solar is going to continue to
plummet in price and therefore a using
gas or coal to to turn the steam
turbines it to make steam to turn the
turbine seas it's not going to be
economical similarly the electrification
of the transportation sector is having
the same effect some are also looking at
the the trend in national regional and
local governance I mentioned this before
but they're predicting a very different
energy future but but let me come back
to Chris you because we talked about
business leaders I want I think you were
getting in a question a moment ago about
capitalism itself and I do want to say a
word on that because there are a lot of
people who say maybe capitalism is the
basic problem I think the current form
of capitalism we have is desperately in
need of reform the short-term outlook is
often mentioned but the way we measure
what is a value to us is also at the
heart of the crisis of modern capitalism
now capitalism is at the base of every
successful economy and it balances
supply and demand unlocks a higher
fraction of the human potential and it's
not going anywhere but it needs to be
reformed because the way we measure
what's valuable now ignores so-called
negative externalities like pollution it
also ignores positive externalities like
investments in education and health care
mental health care family services it
ignores the depletion of resources like
groundwater and topsoil
and the web of living species and it
ignores the distribution of incomes and
net worth so that we have when GDP goes
up
people cheer a tooth 2% 3% Wow 4% and
they think great but it's accompanied by
vast increases in pollution chronic
underinvestment in public goods the
depletion of irreplaceable natural
resources and the worst inequality
crisis we've we've seen in more than a
hundred years that is threatening the
future of both capitalism and democracy
so we have to change it we have to
reform it so reform capitalism but don't
throw it out we're gonna need it as a
tool as we go forward if I solve this
yeah I think that's right and just one
other point the worst environmental
abuses in the last hundred years have
been in jurisdictions that experimented
during the 20th century with the
alternatives to capitalism on the left
and right interesting all right
to last community questions quickly
Chadbourne Bloomquist as you're reading
the tea leaves of the impact of the
current pandemic what do you think in
regard to our response to combating
climate change will be the most
impactful lesson land well that's a very
thoughtful question and and I wish my
answer could rise to the same level on
short notice I would say first don't
ignore the scientists when there is
virtual unanimity among the scientific
and medical experts pay attention don't
let some politician dissuade you I think
president Trump is slowly learning that
it's kind of difficult to Gaslight a
virus he tried to guess like the virus
in Tulsa didn't come off very well and
tragically he decided to recklessly roll
the dice a month ago and ignore the the
recommendations for people to wear masks
and a socially distance and to do the
other things and I think that lesson is
is is beginning to take hold in a much
stronger way but beyond that Chris I
think that this period of time has been
characterized by one of
the most profound opportunities for
people to rethink the patterns of their
lives and to consider whether or not we
can't do a lot of things better and
differently and I think that this rising
generation I mentioned before has been
even more profoundly affected by this
interlude which I hope in soon but I
hope the lessons in der I expect they
will yeah it's amazing how many things
you can do without emitting carbon as
wit that we've been forced to do let's
have one more question here Frank can I
see you are you encouraged by the
ability of people to quickly adapt to
the new normal due to cover 19 as
evidence that people can and will change
their habits to respond to climate
change yes but I think we have to keep
in mind that there is a crisis within
this crisis the the impact on the
African American community which I
mentioned before on the latina latin x
community indigenous peoples the highest
infection rate is in the navajo nation
right now so some of these questions
appear differently to those who are
really getting the brunt of this crisis
and it is unacceptable that we allow
this to continue it it feels one way to
you and me and perhaps the many and our
audience today but for low-income
communities of color that's an entirely
different crisis and we owe it to them
and to all of us to get busy and start
using the best science and solve this
pandemic you know the the phrase
pandemic economic somebody said the
first principle of pandemic economics is
take care of the pandemic and we're not
doing that yet we're seeing the
president try to Goose the economy for
his reelection
never mind the predict
of tens of thousands of additional
American deaths and that is just
unforgivable in my opinion all right
thank you Frank so al you along with
others in the community played a key
role in encouraging Ted to launch this
initiative core countdown thank you for
that and I guess this this conversation
will is continuing among many of us if
you're interested in climate watching
this check out the countdown website at
countdown Ted calm and be part of 1010
2020 when we're trying to put out an
alert to the world that climate can't
wait that that it really matters and
that there's gonna be some amazing
content free to the world on that day
just that Thank You al for your
inspiration and support in doing that I
wonder whether you could end today's
session just by just painting us a
picture you know like how might things
roll out over the next decade or so just
tell it tell us whether there is still a
story of hope here I'd be glad to
forgive I got to get one plug in I'll
make it brief July 18 through July 26
the climate reality project is having a
global training we've already had 8,000
people register you can go to climate
reality calm now a bright future
it begins with all of the kinds of
efforts that you've thrown yourself into
an organizing countdown Chris you and
your team have been amazing
to to to work with and I'm so excited
about the countdown project Ted has an
unparalleled ability to spread ideas
that are worth spreading to raise
consciousness to enlighten people around
the world and it's needed for climate
and the solutions to the climate crisis
like it's never been needed before and I
just want to thank you for what you
personally are doing to organize this
fantastic countdown program
thank you and the world are we gonna do
this do you think do you think that
humanity is gonna pull this off and that
we will that our grandchildren are going
to have beautiful lives where they can
celebrate nature and not spend every day
in fear of the next tornado or tsunami I
am optimistic that we will do it but the
answer is in our hands we have seen dark
times in periods of the pass and we have
risen to meet the challenge we have
limitations of our long evolutionary
heritage and elements of our culture but
we also have the ability to transcend
our limitations and when the chips are
down and when survival is at stake and
when our children and future generations
are at stake we're capable of more than
we sometimes allow ourselves to think we
can do this is such a time I believe we
will rise to the occasion and we will
create a bright clean prosperous just
and fair future I believe it with all my
heart I'll go
thank you for your life of work for all
you've done to elevate this issue and
for spending this time with us now thank
you back at you thank you